So two weeks ago I was a bridesmaid and the reception was actually here,
at the New York Public Library, and I will never forget this wedding. Yes, it was
very beautiful, but, more importantly,
I survived the slick marble floors that are all over this building.
Tile and marble floors are public enemy number one to a stilleto loving girl like
me. See when most people learn to walk
in very high heels, and I had five Inch Nails on that night, they bend their ankle
so that the ball of the foot touches the ground first, you have more stability. I don't
have ankles. So I hit each step on the stilleto, which makes
the possibility of the banana peel wipe-out very likely.
But given a choice between practicality and theatricality, I say go big or go home and go down
in flames if you're going to go.
I guess I'm a bit of a daredevil. Um, I think that the nurses
at Dupont Institute would agree. I spent a lot of time there as a child.
Doctors amputated both of my legs below the knee when I was an infant, and then, when I was five,
I had a major surgery to correct the wonky direction in which my tibia I was growing.
So I had two metal pins to hold the full plaster cast on both legs. I had to use a wheelchair because
I couldn't wear prosthetics. And one of the best things about getting out of a hospital
is the anticipation of the day you return to school. You know I had missed so much class, I
just couldn't wait to get back and see all my friends, but my teacher had a different idea about that.
She tried to prevent me from returning to class because she said that in the
condition I was in I was inappropriate, and that I would be a distraction to the
other students, which of course I was not because of the cast in the wheelchair.
Clearly she needed to make my
difference invisible because she wanted to control her environment and make it fit in
to her idea of
what normal looked like. And it was a lot easier for me to fit in to what normal looked
like, you know, I
wanted that back then.
But instead I had these wooden legs with a rubber foot that the toes broke off of and it was held on with a big, rusty,
you know, bolt that rusted out because I swam in the wooden legs and you're not supposed to swim in
wooden
legs, but, you know the wood rots out too, so there you are in second grade
music
class doing the twist and mid-twist I hear this [splintering noise],
and I'm on the floor and the lower half of my left leg is in splinters over there and the teacher faints on
the piano and the kids are screaming, and all I'm thinking is, "My
parents are going to kill me. I broke my leg." [laughter] It's a
mess. But then a few years later my prosthetist tells me, "Amy we got
waterproofed legs for you. No more rusty bolts!" I mean this is a revelation for me, this is going to change
my
life. I was so excited to get these
legs. Until I saw them. They were made of polypropylene, which is
that white plastic milk jug material. When I say white I'm not talking about skin
color, I'm talking about the color white. The skin color
was the rubber foam foot painted caucasian. [laughter]
Which is the nastiest shade of a nuclear peach that you've ever seen in
your life. It has nothing to do with any human skin tone on the
planet, and these legs were so good at being waterproof that they
were buoyant.
So when I'd go off the high dive I'd go down and come straight back up, feet first.
They were the bane of my existence. [laughter] But then at the Jersey Shore,
one summer. You know, by the time we get there there's like 300 yards of towels between me and the sea and I know
this is where I first hone my ability to run really fast. I was the white flash.
I didn't want to feel hundreds of pairs of eyes staring at me.
And so, I get myself into the ocean, and you know I was a good swimmer. But no amount of
swimming technique, and you know to control buoyant
legs. S-so, at some point I get caught in a rip current, and
I'm migrating from my vantage point of where I could see my parents' towel and I'm like, you know,
taking in water, and I'm fighting fighting fighting all I could think to do was pop off these legs
and put one under
each arm pit with the peach feet sticking up and just bob, like, just wait.
Just, like, someone's gotta find me you know and, and
a lifeguard did. And
I'm sure he will collect for therapy bills.
You know, you get the, like, they don't show that on Baywatch. Ugghh. [laughter]
But they saved my life, those legs, and then I was fourteen at Easter Sunday, and
I was going to be wearing a
dress that I had purchased with my own money. The first thing I ever bought
that wasn't on sale.
Momentous event you never forget it. I had a paper route since I was twelve and I went to The Limited
and I bought this dress that I thought was the height of sophistication. Sleeveless Safari dress, belted,
hit the knee. Coming downstairs with, in my living room, my father's waiting to take us to church.
He takes one look at me he says, "That doesn't look right. Go
upstairs and change." I was like, "My super
classy dress? What are you talking about? It's the best thing I own." And he said, "No, you can see the need join.
when you walk. Doesn't look right, it's inappropriate to go out like
that. Go change." And I think something snapped in me.
I refused to change,
and it was the first time I defied my father.
I refused to hide something about myself that was true, and I refused to be
embarrassed about something so that other people could feel more comfortable.
And I was grounded for that defiance. And so after church the extended
family convenes at my grandmother's house and everybody is complimenting me on how nice I look in this dress. And I'm like,
"Really? You think I look nice? Cause my parents think I look innapropraite." [laughter] And I outed
them. [laughter]
Kind of mean really. But I think the public utterance of
this idea that I should somehow hide myself was so shocking to hear that
it changed their mind
about why they were doing it. You know I had
always
managed to get through life with someone of a positive attitude but I think this was the start
of me being able to accept myself. You know OK. I'm not normal. I
have strengths, I got weaknesses. I had always been athletic. But it
wasn't till college that I started this adventure in track and field. You know I had gone through a lifetime
of being given legs that just barely got me by,
and I thought well maybe I'm just having the wrong conversations with the wrong people.
Maybe I need to go find people who say,
"Yes. We can create anything for you in the space between where your
leg ends and the ground."
And so I started working with engineers, fashion designers, sculptors, hollywood prosthetic
makeup artists, wax museum designers to build legs for me. And I
decided I wanted to be the fastest woman in the world on artificial legs.
And I was lucky enough to arrive in track at just the right time to be the first person to
get these radical sprinting
legs modeled after the hind leg of a cheetah, the fastest thing that
runs. Woven carbon fiber, and I was able to set three
world records with those legs. And they made no attempt at
approximating humanness. But then I got these incredibly lifelike silicone legs, hand
painted, capillaries, veins. Hey, I can be as tall as I want to
be so I get different legs for different heights. I don't have to shave. My,
I can wear open toed shoes in the winter. And I
can
most importantly, I can opt out of the cankles I most
certainly would have
inherited genetically.
So then I get these legs made for me
by the late, great Alexander McQueen, and they
were hand carved of solid
ash with grape vines and magnolias all over them. Six inch heel.
And I was able to walk run ways of the world with supermodels.
And I was suddenly in this whirlwind of adventure and excitement
and, you know, I was being invited to go around the world and speak about these adventures. And
now I had, you know, legs look like glass, legs covered in feathers, porcelain
legs, jellyfish legs, all wearable
sculpture. And I get this call from a guy who had seen me
speak years ago when I was at the beginning of my track career and he says,
"We loved it, we loved it. We want to you to come back." And it was clear to me, he didn't know all these amazing things
that had happened to me since my sports career. So as I'm telling him he says,
"Whoa,
whoa whoa whoa, hold on, Amy.
The reason everybody liked
you, all those years ago is because you were this sweet, vulnerable,
naive girl,
I'm afraid that if you walk on stage today, and you
are this polished young
woman, with too many accomplishments," for real. He said
that. "I'm afraid they won't like you."
Wow. He apparently didn't think I was
vulnerable enough now. He was asking me to be less
than, a little more
downtrodden. He was asking me to disable myself for him and his audience,
and what was so shocking to me about that
was I realized I had moved past mere acceptance of
my difference. I was having fun with my difference. Thank God I'm not normal.
I get to be extraordinary, and I'll
decide what is a weakness and what might be a strength. And so
I refuse his request.
And a few days later I'm walking in downtown Manhattan at street fair, and I get this tug on my shirt,
and I look down it's of little girl I had met a year earlier when she was at a pivotal moment in her life.
She had been born with a brittle bone disease that resulted in her left leg being 7
centimeters shorter than her right. And she wore a brace and orthopedic shoes,
and they got her by.
But she wanted to do more. And like all Internet
savvy kindergartners she gets on the computer and
Googles new leg. And she comes up with dozens of images
of prosthetics, many of them
mine. And she prints them out, goes to school, does show and tell on it, comes home
and makes a startling pronouncement
to her parents. "I want to get rid of my bad leg,"
she says. "When can I get a new leg?"
And ultimately that was the decision her parents and doctors made for her. And so here she
was 6 months after the amputation, and right there in the middle of the street fair
she hikes up her jeans, like, to show me her cool new leg, and
it's pink, and it's tattooed with the characters of High School Musical 3.
Replete
with red sequin Mary Janes on her feet,
and she was proud of it. She was proud of herself.
And the marvelous thing is that this 6 year old
understood something that it took me 20 something years to get.
But we did both
discover that when we can celebrate and truly own
what it is that makes us different, we're able to find the source of our
greatest creative
power. Thank you.
Lou.